this episode is made possible by
Skillshare home to over 20,000 classes
that could help you learn a new life
skill sign up using the link below and
get your first 2 months completely free
[Music]
if you've seen Star Wars or Star Trek or
any number of blockbuster sci-fi movies
you know how popular the idea of space
warfare is giant vessels blasting at
each other while smaller ships zip
around blowing each other up with lasers
and photon torpedoes what's not to love
it's good fun and we all know it's
fiction that might not be the case for
much longer though we might not have the
technology to build a Death Star just
yet the White House has unveiled their
plan to create a new branch of the u.s.
military a so called space force if we
do end up militarizing space what will
that mean for space exploration or for
the future of warfare now before you get
all up in arms we need to clarify a
couple things first we already kind of
have a military group in charge of
operations in space the US Air Force
Space Command space command is mostly in
charge of keeping the nation's
satellites safe including from foreign
aggressors the United States relies on
an extensive array of satellites for all
sorts of applications from GPS to
weather to communications at this point
our entire infrastructure is built on
the backs of these essential pieces of
equipment with the announcement of the
proposed space force many critics
suggested that there was no need for a
new branch of the military when we
already have the Air Force Space Command
that being said the transition would be
very similar to what we saw with the Air
Force in 1947 the Air Force used to be a
subsection of the army like the US Army
Air Force became its own entity the Air
Force the US Air Force Space Command
will likely become a new independent
branch the space Force while critics
speculate that there's no need for an
entire branch devoted to outer space
others believe it's the next logical
step in military development especially
since developed nations are increasingly
reliant on satellites and therefore
increasingly vulnerable to foreign
attacks another thing people get wrong
about militarizing space is that they
assume the outer space treaty prohibits
weaponizing space vessels this is only
partly correct the treaty which the US
UK Russia and a hundred and four other
nations have signed prohibits the
placing of nuclear weapons anywhere in
space it also prohibits building
military bases testing weapons or
conducting military maneuvers on any
celestial body however the treaty does
not prohibit the use of
weapons which are still deadly in fact
Russia has already sent at least one
serious weapon to space in the dark
depths of the Cold War the Soviet Union
secretly built and installed a 14.5
millimeter cannon that could reportedly
fire between 950 and 5,000 rounds per
minute and accurately hit targets up to
2 miles away
of course the tremendous recoil
generated by the cannon would have made
it hard to use effectively in space
requiring the use of thrusters to
counteract its momentum and the entire
20-ton space station had to be rotated
to line up their shot the weapon was
only tested once just before deorbiting
the space station other more effective
conventional weapons would include
kinetic bombardment rods
telephone-pole-sized cylinders of
tungsten which could be aided by a
rudimentary guidance system to hit
targets on earth striking with enough
kinetic energy to do massive damage even
without explosives the problem with this
type of weapon is that it would have to
be launched from a satellite which would
have to be positioned slowly and
precisely into an orbit that would
intersect with the intended target which
could take a very long time much longer
than say a ground-based ICBM at this
point we really don't have much in the
way of space weaponry that would be more
effective than earth-based tools but
that doesn't mean we won't see space
weapons in the near future these will
most likely be basic defenses for
satellites but if countries start
pulling out of the outer space treaty we
should be concerned
so these militarizing space a good thing
or a bad thing well we have to look at
it rationally sure space force might
sound silly and it might be kind of
disappointing to think that outer space
could become just another battlefield
rather than a purely scientific domain
but we have to realize there are some
very positive possibilities first we
know that Russia and North Korea have
been incredibly antagonistic towards the
Western world being able to defend our
satellites from foreign adversaries is
absolutely necessary to prevent a
crippling of Western nations and a
collapse of communication and navigation
systems another important consideration
is that any time the military gets
involved in research and development for
a new challenge the technology
inevitably trickles down to the average
consumer in this instance with the
military pouring huge amounts of money
into developing space technology if NASA
isn't going to get a budget raised
anytime soon this is the next best thing
new propulsion technologies guidance
systems life-support communications the
possibilities are endless and could
easily be applied to purely scientific
pursuits the military being involved in
could also inspire huge numbers of young
people to pursue a career in aerospace
engineering or astrophysics or any
number of important fields that could
fill roles in both the military and the
public sector and perhaps even rekindle
enough interest to spark a new space
race if this new space force really
wants to be useful they can spend their
time tracking non-military threats in
addition to foreign interference giant
asteroids pose a huge threat to our
existence and could easily wipe us off
the face of the earth in one random
collision the military could develop new
detection technologies and tools or
weapons that could intercept redirect or
destroy dangerous asteroids before they
ever got close to Earth even if this
proposed new branch of the military
comes from a misguided or paranoid place
investing huge sums of money into space
technology could be the driver we need
to really excel beyond Earth and usher
in a new age of space exploration and
scientific understanding there's so much
to learn when it comes to space
exploration and while that may be a bit
beyond the reach of most of us we can
learn plenty of other useful skills with
Skillshare Skillshare is an online
learning community for creators with
over 20,000 classes and everything from
photography to graphic design to
productivity marketing fine art and more
I love Skillshare because anytime I'm
bored I can just put on a class and
learn something worthwhile a premium
membership gives you unlimited access to
high-quality classes on useful topics so
you can improve your skills unlock new
opportunities and do the work you love
I'm actually working on my own intro to
photography course I'm not going to give
you an estimate of when it'll be done
because it's taking much longer than I
expected but it'll be available for you
to watch at some point in the near
future join me and the millions of other
students already learning on Skillshare
today with a special offer just for you
guys get two months of Skillshare
completely free to start learning
amazing new skills today visit skill
share by following the link below
[Music]
[Music]